about what specifically who's watching
this we're gonna have every everybody
right now so we have anyone from the
ages of you know 14 all the way up to 40
some 20 to 50 but a lot of them are
concentrated in around like the 2528
group passionate about science futurism
business entrepreneurship really
passionate about those things we're
talking about our audience we're talking
about you guys at home right now so that
is don't tell them that's kind of the
concentration of the audience so we'll
definitely you know we'll definitely
match this out with your audience as
well we'll send it out we'll all co
promote it of course all that good stuff
joy send in questions yeah they can via
the YouTube livestream they can send in
questions okay yeah and then yeah so
we've been live already we've been
talking but let's go ahead and start off
alright here we go
hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Sakia and today we're have
the pleasure sitting now Michelle Israel
thank you for having me thank you so
much for coming on really appreciate it
I love the Hat well thank you it's good
well thank you there's a story whether
you want to hear yeah let's get to some
of the story I want to introduce you a
little bit and then you we have a
seven-time author on our hands we have a
20-year contributor to Forbes to Fast
Company Business Insider this week
Businessweek that is a lot of writing
that's so cool how it's so much writing
and trying to communicate important
concepts to people and then also the CEO
of transformation group so that's about
the last like year and almost a half
approach over a year yeah and it began
at South by Southwest in March last year
nice yeah and so the focus of you know
this recent endeavor of yours is to get
people prepared for the arguments of
reality explosion yes yes that's super
exciting I'm really excited to talk all
of that great let's walk walk us through
walk us through some of the the paths
that led you to where you are today I
mean 20 years of writing about all the
stuff in all these books
get passionate about all this but it
that's a long story can we have an extra
hour why I'm very old remember that the
my professional career is divided almost
equally between writing and consulting
as a writer I loved everything about it
except the vial of poverty that's
attached to it so when I get
sufficiently pissed off at not making
enough money I then start consulting
which I really don't mind doing except
then I miss the writing and invariably I
go back and forth so right now for the
first time in my life I'm very seriously
trying to do both and I'm starting to
research my next book with a new partner
so that's that's the short version that
is super duper short ok so writing and
consulting back and forth little dance
and there has been enough money though
that you've earned from writing to where
you didn't have to consult for periods
of time that kind of a thing and then on
the consultation side of things you were
consulting businesses about the future
technologies and how to get them ready
for them and mostly transformation group
is trying to help big brands and
enterprise clients to adapt to the I
hate to use the word tsunami but tsunami
have changed primarily right now it's AR
and VR increasingly automated machines
are coming in yo
rivets that such machine learnings
becoming an issue for us so what we're
consulting about is expanding basepart
on what people are asking us to do based
part on we see they are they are part of
the bigger picture yeah man the
explosion is
tsunami it's when you look you know it's
funny because here we are in the heart
of we're a RvR and a whole lot of other
cool stuff is happening and I hear all
the time from people in the buildings
around us how slow it's moving how
disappointed it is haha but but the
truth of the matter is this is an
adoption of a world changing technology
yeah in a faster space than anything
that has ever come before it in the
history of humankind
yes correct that's what's going exactly
I always I always like to make that
reference especially to people that
already have a tremendous amount of
wealth because then they get access to
the newest day eyes and the newest bio
technologies and newest space
colonization's and brain augmentations
and they get access to it much faster
than cryptocurrencies they get x2 much
faster than the rest of the and now
because of that because of all those
different technologies moving forward
and more quickly it's changing our world
so so much and I'm just very fascinated
by people like you that I've also
analyzed the way they are going to be
affecting the world and they make those
right correct predictions prepare
businesses for them so walk us through a
little bit of that so maybe like with
the age of context right that was one of
the getting businesses ready for mobile
and sensors and data yeah since 2010 I
and people I work with have been just
noticing a fundamental change in
fundamental change like paradigm shift
our terms are used all the time but in
computing there have been only three
fundamental changes to be completed so
far
in the beginning there were mainframes
and they're in the basement and computer
scientists and advanced degree engineers
would use timeshare and come in at 2:00
in the morning and they were talked to
these machines by punching holes and
pieces of paper we later learned you
could [ __ ] an election in 2000 with
the same putting holes in piece of paper
but in this case this was unheard of
that we could communicate with machines
ask them questions and get answers a few
years passed and we could go from the
mainframe in the basement used by only
really big-time scientific professionals
to the net knowledge worker in desks in
big buildings for big corporations and
this changed everything
this changed information has changed the
way companies and customers talk to each
other
it created a need to connect things
through the Ethernet to connect things
eventually through the World Wide Web
then all of a sudden a couple of hippies
in Silicon Valley named jobs and Wozniak
came up with something that was really
called cool and we had the Mac and that
was the second transformation that
brought computing from the work place to
the home and that changed a lot and the
kids junior high school kids were using
computers for the first time the
important thing wasn't just location was
that we moved first from programming to
typing on a keypad to a mouse that you
could do things by pointing and clicking
the ability to see graphic design even
those in great first so that's the
second transformation the third
transformation probably everybody here
remembers it came in 2006 with the
iPhone it wasn't the first smartphone
but it was the smartphone that allowed
us to take our computing wherever we
went to do things not by programming or
typing or pointing and clicking but by
touching and swiping
yeah and this change everything it was
faster it was more mobile nothing else
yes a few years back technology that
starting late 80s into the 90s - saw the
enormous Li big complex expensive
problems for the Pentagon for Boeing for
MIT started creating headsets that
talked to computers more efficiently
than we could with phones and put the
computing in front of our faces which is
easier than here yeah right now in a few
years that could be sitting here and
getting notes from him telling me to
talk up or stop coughing or something
like that but now what I would have to
do is look down and you would be talking
and they would be seeing the ignoring it
yeah so now we can put things in front
of our faces it creates a new kind of
entertainment but it also is
revolutionising the the underbelly of
the enterprise work logistics warehouse
fulfillment order workers people working
on length anywhere they can nowhere
can't spray education surgeons can work
yeah I'm still on the enterprise and yes
on the enterprise on the enterprise side
though you do have training coming to
college driver began by helping
quarterbacks practice without getting
hit by linebacker yeah it Stanford in
two years later 140,000 wall-mount
employees are being trained with the
same with the same company software a
modified for Walmart employees and among
other things as teaching them is
something that you never thought of a
computer teaching humans but it's
teaching them empathy it's teaching the
workers to feel sorry for the poor or
Walmart shoppers on the day after
Christmas when this pandemonium going on
and
in the old days the Walmart employees
there's videos of it just left the scene
because the customers are too much some
of them might have a good day someone
might have a bad day someone I have a
medium day how do you interact with all
the different ones how do i what whoa
dude I'm not here just in general
there's a multitude of personalities
that approach you in the retail and
service industry and then how does every
single person that is in that position
of employment interact and engage with
that it it changes everything because
now the technology starts assisting us
search not only informing us with data
gathering is starting to make a smaller
in real time yeah because now when we
have the headsets on we have a shorter
distance to travel between we were
interfacing with the technology of the
eye and the brain yes where the
decisions are made and it's also not
limited to the bandwidth of our meat
sticks pressing on it it's more on
sticks yeah I would love if you use them
you have to attribute it no not at all
okay good well isn't it my meat stick
meat puppet isn't it player uh meat meat
stick initially came from Elan talking
about the limited bandwidth of
communication from the meat stick but
that's why I can have it for free anyone
knows I'm not worth suing so we're all
clear hahaha and iran says meat puppets
a lot and I say flesh vehicle a lot in
reference to our body meat puppet flesh
vehicle the so that's the way that we
communicate about that so if murder we
used to say meet me in outer space dude
I think Ron might remember meet me in
outer space
meet me in outer space and we'll bless
me at the rocket base will blast off to
outer space yeah you separate parts I'm
not I know but the way you're resembling
was all your own well who did it maybe
we will close out with that son whoo-hoo
hunter okay thank you have fun I didn't
want to say that because tab went bad oh
he found God in the Republican Party so
I don't talk about him very often
all right let's okay but so back on
track I also want to include that you've
been you've been listing all these
different transformations that have
happened you also helped in 2000 what
year but the popularization of social
media that was about 2005 or so so I was
right around the time of these iPhones
yeah yeah um the first book was written
with Robert Scoble and it was at a time
when people were getting fired for
blogging including at Google Robert was
one of the first corporate bloggers who
didn't get fired he was Microsoft but a
there's a book out nobody cares what you
had for lunch it was looked upon as the
purview of lowly teenagers and Robin and
I wrote a book that said hey you're
getting it all wrong
this is an opportunity for companies to
talk directly to scale to customers it's
a scalable way of having conversations
with the people you depend upon to make
you money and a few companies yeah Dell
and Ford particularly Comcast particular
during in the companies in Australia
Telstra the phone company down there
they immediately embraced what we were
saying and they changed business
directions and they started instead of
firing people hiring people to blog and
so that helped Robert and I separately
build our careers and brought us
together a couple more times to write
other books that was actually the star
of the
nation that is now reaching almost
reaching fulfillment with AR and they
are it will go even further as other
machines at John Markoff from the New
York Times called the machines of loving
Grace and a great book and these are
machines that feel empathize look at you
know your patterns know your preferences
know where your eyes are going
understand when you get bored understand
when you get excited understand when you
are foreign to the person in front of
you or you know just faking it with a
with facial recognition that shows
you're not really smiling well yeah and
that's probably something so big and so
incomprehensible at this point that we
get a fulfillment that probably carries
out through the entire century that
we're now just beginning
the pinpoint of it right now is AR they
are because we cannot get to them until
we're right looking right till we can
move in all directions looking around
until we have no wires and tethers yeah
and that's what's going to happen very
quickly in the next five years let's say
yeah exactly
I think 2021 but I keep getting called a
futurist no I just take gases attracted
a whole lot of people definitely and you
know perhaps magically people survive
surprisingly and make the Aged happen in
a couple of months I doubt it but that
would happen that way so the doop dabble
on so you're allowed to know you're not
at all but this is this is great so I'm
really fascinated by these
transformations that occurred throughout
time in order to get us here and I
really enjoyed the the personal computer
entering every single home being
profound and then also the iPhone
entering now I think only just a couple
billion people don't have the devices
which is insanely great and hopefully in
like five or seven years the same thing
will be true with augmented reality
there will only be a couple billion
people that don't have it and then how
will that affect our world when you are
upright looking in every single
direction and having these augmentations
to your primary sense of vision there's
so many you are listing all the
enterprise ones then we have all the
educational ones for young people - or
even job retraining there's so many
there I get to see your social security
number I like all that good hacking so
there's a couple things like who's
actually working with the privacy of the
data who's working with
ensuring that we are safe and secure I
could write two books answering the
question you asked you already wrote one
of them but the fourth transformation
subtitle says will change everything and
for those who know Robert Scoble he's
very absolutist in his views and he I
had written the subtitle will change
almost everything says no it's
everything everything won't change this
woman and I really couldn't come up with
something that wouldn't eventually
change you know the tiebreaker was our
editor said screw it it's the headline
so nobody has yet in the one year since
the books been out said wait a minute
won't change this yes yes you know
somebody said it won't change love yeah
well there is change love you know
absolute age love yeah well would it not
change nothing you will change
everything today well it will change
climate control it'll I cannot think of
thinking what it won't change what is
important is a moment in time that will
not be noted because I do not know the
moment in time when the center of a
digital life moved from the desktop to
the thing in her hands yeah and I don't
know the moment when it'll move from our
hands to our glasses yeah and I do not
know when those glasses will go from VR
and contain so that you can't walk down
Market Street without being a candidate
for the Darwin Award because you can't
see anything but the other world yeah
you're in the Oasis for better or worse
they are right now the greatest value of
it isn't its full potential which it
I'll look at you and will be a little
tag over here in the corner saying you
name what you do why I'm talking to you
and a reminder not to say anything
stupid because those people are watching
at some point this becomes everything
and I can sit here go into the sir
we're watching Bernadette rockets from
outer space I can come back here and
that disappears I'm here he's telling me
to stop moving around so much it will do
everything and the heads will be up and
her hands will be free and it will solve
problems that we haven't thought of yet
no one ever realized that when we got
these phones it would be an end to
boredom as we know it standing in
supermarket lines we're not reading the
headlines and National Enquirer it's not
even there anymore we're sitting here
and we're maybe we're playing games or
we're looking like we're talking to
somebody in text on our heads are going
to be up and we're going to be seeing
all these things that we're going to be
choosing what knowledge we have yeah
we're going to be sitting here and
actually swimming the Great Barrier Reef
we're going to be undergoing surgery and
swimming the Great Barrier Reef while
the surgeon has practiced cutting my
chest open and repairing my heart all
week last week doing the operation in VR
before he actually does it on me laying
in his bed at home you're an operative
yeah and now he's there and he's really
doing it but he's not really doing it
because an AI powered scalpel will be
helping him not make a mistake and if he
gets the hiccups the scalpel will take
over the controls yeah everything is
going to change with the technology
that's coming in
I don't know where to take that what was
the second half of what you asked you
know years listening all the amazing
ways that it's already impacting our
world you know I wrote a book that was
written in 2000 came out in 2000 that
was written in early 2017 and about 30%
of the things that we said would happen
have happened and 30% of the things that
were happening have changed dramatically
Stryver we wrote about talking about
quarterbacks not having to get sacked by
their own linebackers and practice and
the same technology is training Walmart
workers next year everybody's gonna say
well yes it is so it's going to be
training target workers
yeah and IKEA workers yeah you just
other temperaments around here I hear
it's not happening fast enough you know
there are those who expected this is
going to be the AR Christmas that
everybody after this was going to be
using cool AR of the air stuff all the
time and it didn't happen that way and
there's a great disappointment here but
in the last four months 13 million
people have downloaded apps are for
vodka and I don't know the number for
Google it's harder to pull out of Google
I guess but let's say 25 million people
are using air on their phones in the
first four months of its existence and
people say it's not happening fast
enough
wake up folks people take karyam to have
other lives besides this but by this
time next year people will expect their
apps to be a RV arcade yeah
and they'll probably have a setting that
says put it on 2d when they don't want
that 3d react probably because the
battery is getting low because the AR is
moving so much faster than the battery
yeah yeah
Ron can we get a witch witch witch PTZ
should I shut point this at I want to
show right across from right across from
me okay so let's open up our camera app
whoop
all right so we got our camera wrap up
were you know we're just getting great
placement for the iPhone 10 personal so
here we're gonna go to the top hamburger
bar and then we're gonna go to the a are
stickers button wrong can you see it
yeah cool so we go to the AR stickers
and then you know here's you know
stormtrooper yes click and drag it bring
it on and drop him and Ron can you see
that
alright cool so you know there's a clue
right there on the surface of the table
and so yeah and so as you move around so
does the stone so does a stormtrooper
and so this is just a little bit of
insight into you know you got it on your
phone right now you know under the AR
stickers on on your Android phone so but
since you marveled at that yeah I went
around the corner from here visited
Prezi yeah they showed me how I can do
that stuff in my next presentation which
means I was once a PR guy I launch
PowerPoint that's the world to forgive
me they have not but now instead of
slides behind us when we speak we're
going to have little AR characters
running all over the stage what we speak
we're going to be immersed with our
presentation yeah and probably they've
only had Oh less than a million people
adapt that so far YouTube has some
really cool stuff done done at the last
Ted on that part isin everybody where EA
are and watching the presentation they
just see it on the screen behind him and
instead of looking at him on the stage
they look up there and they see I have a
car called augmentations house yeah but
that means they have exactly what you
showed yeah but they have to be looking
at the screen instead of at the person
today today yeah today today yeah but
where is it gonna go how fast is it
gonna can't they know I don't know how
fast is going to get there because
things like battery power 5g they're all
this infrastructure crap nobody's really
we're not interested in five gene hub
did the tower is on with the ranges and
how it bounces off of but we just
with the action we just wanted in our
glasses we just want a battery that
doesn't heat up when we have a headset
on correct in when that happens when it
gets easy enough when it gets long
enough without deteriorating the battery
when all that comes together but lip
blip but there are no heavier it's
nobody gets excited we don't have a
conference unless you're a professional
about 5g tower installations and the
complexities thereof or about drone
safety hazards all this stuff gets Figg
click click it's gone no longer problem
you forget there ever was a problem does
anybody remember the last time they used
I can't say I always say whiteout but
nobody knows what why how it is the old
days oh boy oh my god whiteout we know
what whiteout is carbon paper carbon
paper I forgive me for this too but my
one of my Pierrot the carbon paper I
make copies on the second copy yeah when
you write you get the yellow slip a five
years past non-disclosure but one of my
PR agencies was acquired by ketchup PR
and that was they came to me and they
said we want to buy you because we're
brain dead on this consumer technology
this is the 90s and there's what we
called it why do you come in we'll give
you a lot of money will make you the EVP
of Ketchum worldwide for consumer
technology and I got there we sat down
at my desk and I found I was working on
a deck rainbow max simulation terminal
and I got my orientation of Ketchum
whose claim to fame is they did PR for
carbon paper in nineteen oh and that's
how they got started in the PR business
and they were at that time the sixth
largest PR agency in the world
and I was in awe that this company's
culture started with carbon paper and it
just hired somebody to handle Silicon
Valley stuff and would not give me a Mac
but only gave me a Mac emulator because
Dec was a client until it died later
that year the technology used very
quickly cultures that succeeded
previously get embedded with systems in
place with devices in place with right
out with carbon paper with broad modems
and one day it's gone and kids come
along and the people who are 52 these
kids they and they don't understand how
minecraft changes the world yeah
minecraft let's preschoolers learn to
program thinking 3d when they come up
with something really cool they don't
call up an intellectual property lawyer
they posted on YouTube to share for free
mm-hmm this changes global economics
this changes global cultures this
lessens the importance of political
political powers because now people are
talking to each other and they don't
have to talk in the languages of English
and Chinese they can share in code they
can soon share in 3d because they can
see each other in 3d we can now see a
street vendor now but very soon or not
so far into the distance we can see a
street vendor selling artisan goods on
the streets of Beijing and push a button
and have them delivered maybe by a drone
to our homes in Marin County California
and that's not far away there's no woman
it happens so is dit dit dit dit dit dit
when Apple or magically or Google or
somebody comes up with a device that has
all that stuff in it and when we don't
think about is the AI I'm not going to
do tech babble I get tired of tech devil
I'm not interested in the AI we're not
interested in the refreshment we're not
interested in anything nothing wow this
is cool Wow oh geez I didn't know he was
arrested for that I guess I'll go
socialize with run over there our lives
change the world changes politics change
currency changes you mentioned cyber
currency one that I'm not up to speed on
but do you realize that the purpose of
blockchain or whatever places it if it
gets replaced is the demolition of
government as we know it because
government elevation in general yeah it
democratizes money Wow it eliminates the
ability for governments to tax it
eliminates trade wars which I think
China would like right now but instead
we're gonna have one with them
apparently this is all happening in
little blips all over the place and it
makes so much noise in their heads and
then we want to go to a place like OSS
and ready player one where we can just
get away from all that crap and that's
the other reason why there's a
revolution going on the way we entertain
ourselves the way we escape from things
comes into the headsets this time we're
talking more about VR in China they have
an experiment going on with virtual
teachers as good as they have been
population control practices they still
produce kids much faster than they can
educate teachers so they're
experimenting now with giving children
and a classroom headsets yeah and
letting the classroom be a little bit
bigger and a cell has to be a classroom
so that they can learn to socialize yeah
and working groups and all of that sort
of stuff yeah
but now the kids can picture pick a
teacher I might picture a young and
nubile babe your preference might be for
an old wise man I don't know and you can
then choose a an avatar who has a
personality the old wise to be kindly
encouraging that or even the Machine
learns about what you prefer I'm coming
to that because as you study the Machine
knows what you're looking at at all
times if you're a smart kid they teach
you faster if you're a slow kid they
teach you with greater patience if you
lose interest they give you a pop quiz
if you're getting bored and you haven't
gone away yet they may just pause and
tell you a joke and give you a
five-minute recess and then put you back
in well when I don't want it I just take
it off and that's the difference between
the glasses and a neural prosthetic no
prosthetic the ability to turn it off
might not be in your full control I
think neural prosthetics
are going to be a purview in areas like
prison reform where homicidal maniacs
are going to get reprogrammed I don't
see anything happening in the next
near-term future where it becomes an
everyday application I can't see anybody
going to work with and attaching to a
neural prosthetic unless they're a
volunteer for an experiment or something
we were chatting about personalizing
education personalizing learning that is
super important as well with the
proliferation of AI and robotics now we
can also retrain people using augmented
reality so that way all the jobs that
are being lost their own the
world to things like autonomous vehicles
accountants and many ways law even
doctors of all these augmentations that
are occurring service industry retail
industry augmented reality will help
them potentially become a worker in the
field of robotics and AI so could the a
are actually retrain a service industry
worker that became robotic that the
robot took over that work could that
service industry worker learned through
AR how to better design or program some
ethics on that bottle or design the
system of interaction between the human
and the computer the HCI human-computer
interaction so that's so interesting
being able to retrain through it as well
teach kids kids running through
augmented reality as well it's about as
controversial issue as there is and
again I know studio audiences like brief
answers but there are examples of
autistic kids being trained to look both
ways before crossing the street so for
the first time in history some autistic
kids can cross streets of course this is
just right now being experimented on so
if you have an autistic kid don't get my
headset and send about to the stream
with problems come in to me with
retraining is
the person needing retraining may be of
a certain age headspace and culture that
they cannot suddenly go from being a
storm window builder in Erie
Pennsylvania to being a AI programmer in
Silicon Valley definitely the changing
historically has come much more
massively for the next generation and
very often as South of Market area
illustrates younger generations create
jobs and fields that older generations
didn't think of so they're not going to
be able to retrain you retraining also
involves culture people who are a
certain way are unlikely to change it is
very unlikely that a trump supporter
will become an Obama type candidate
supporter in the next election
because they've gone through life with
certain value certain ethics and
Retraining ethics with a Clockwork
Orange type torturous effects may not be
financially feasible or realistic or
have a high success rate for a very long
period of time I see much more the new
technologies creating new job
opportunities for new generations
I think you disagree with that so you
can push back if you know it is creating
new opportunities for another
generations I I think I'm really curious
about is it going to create more jobs
than its route than it's gonna replace a
mission John Markov before in machines
of loving grace which is the best AI for
business book that I've seen so far he
pointed out that until 2000 I could have
the year run 13 or 14 every wave of
Technology has created more jobs and
better jobs than it's replaced and he
brought that all the way back to when
Tall Ships replaced rowing teams and
Viking boats you know in the side
effects also created more problems more
people died when ships went out to the
Big C then died while rowing up canals
so with AI and what is happening now
there may not be this continuing
creation of new jobs at the expenses of
old jobs bring this into the reality of
lights out factories lights out
factories for people who don't know have
gotten rid of the humans in there so you
don't need to spend any money on
electricity
you don't need coffee breaks or a whole
lot of things you can just have these
machines working in absolute darkness
and once a week the human comes by and
does whatever monitoring and inspection
is needed yo saves a lot of money but it
doesn't have jobs that get replaced at
any point and it takes fewer workers to
create the technology for lights-out
Factory then get laid off for right now
the layoffs have created jobs in other
parts of the world and the workers and
other parts of the world have devolved
from say an agrarian culture to an
industrial culture until now the US has
always gone for the most technical
culture has been a global leader by
going for the most technical culture of
recruiting people from all over the
world to to come to the United States to
work well now for the first year in
history in 2017 more Chinese citizens
left the United States for jobs in China
that came to the United States for jobs
in America this is a trend I think will
has hit a turning point but I see this
trend is continuing for a long period of
time I think we should talk about this
so with the proliferation of our
augments reality AI all this new
biotechs space colonization's all these
technologies and if you hit up the
coffee route good ok it's trying to be
subtle yeah yeah good I'm glad you got
it in yeah
so package for the know he wanted to be
subtle he wanted to be discreet you got
to talk about it don't you know nothing
about being a TV oh no it's good it's
it's fun to be able to point stuff out
in but it's also fun to be discreet oh
right pour the water on my host so what
so what do you think about globalization
what do where do you think we're going
with AI China and how do we work
together
that gets even more political than I've
dabbled in so far I think that the
United States has reversed a course that
we have the course that made us the
world leader begins at the end of World
War two
it begins actually with one of the most
horrible things that ever happened in
the atomic bomb and since that time we
have been the global leader in every way
shape and form relates to jobs I'm sorry
relating to technology and its impact on
jobs on the industry and education and
quality of life for whatever
improvements to environment they've been
obviously they haven't been enough to
automobiles to flying it just goes on
and on the u.s. is there for almost
every innovation in those areas until
now now we have a political head of
state who ran on the slogan of make
America great again and it seems that by
that he is going back to a time where
we're trying things that have failed in
the past tariffs for example returning
industrial work here the lunacy of
things like putting a terrifying for
aluminum which helps five American
aluminum making companies and damages a
hundred and forty five or something like
that
companies that buy aluminum and a
quarter of the price one is Chinese so
we are now heading in a period where our
leadership is likely to be damaged for a
very long time our historic partners
don't know if they can trust us anymore
if we get a different administration
they don't know if it'll just keep
flipping and flopping and the last thing
they want is an unstable and
unpredictable partner
so I think there's a huge opportunity
for other countries there are two that
are making big plays one is China which
I think is doing it quite wisely and is
to be worried about and the other is
Russia which is trying as far as I can
see to reestablish the Soviet Union and
is doing a frightening ly good job of it
so I think the balance of power in the
world is going to change um
I think though that what has happened in
America is hitting a nerve all over the
world as we saw with bricks at Germany's
problems and finding a leadership I mean
most of the world looked at Merkel as
this fixture for the next 30 years and
she managed to hold on to power but she
barely grasped on to it at least the way
it appeared to me the EU itself is
really in more powerful position as ours
is reduced but so how will we work
together
I don't have been observed then a
corrector um okay I don't know how to do
that I okay no I was raised when they
thought the United Nations was going to
create a global government that never
got it listened to and that was actually
pretty close to the consensus in the 50s
as I grew up it was the whole world over
here and then over there were the
Russians and their satellites there was
a world it was very simple it was going
to be like that till one side one and
then we'd all be happy we need the
United Federation of Planets the ufp the
United Federation gene Roddenberry
Star Trek Star Trek United Federation of
Planets I'm sorry yes I was on a
different enterprise this is a very
fascinating conversation Michelle it's a
you're wonderful human being
thanks for being you yeah we really
appreciate it yeah is that our sorry
enough did we just no I know I'm just
saying if I get up and give you a buddy
I will do it at the end maybe we'll come
in yeah okay how about we must have done
something wrong no no no let's wander
into a little bit about these
technologies okay you say you're an
observer more so it's been a contest but
let me interrupt you for a minute I get
asked a lot whether I think this is good
or bad and I looked at a lot of facts
hopefully in balance and I tend to err
err on the side if this is good and I
tend to error that this is going to
happen sooner because I forget about all
those little glitches like that
but whether it is good or bad it is
going to happen it is inevitable what do
I think the United States can do I think
the regime change is a really good idea
but I don't know if we will do it and
I'm not in the business of advocating
that we should do it I'm in the business
of observing how politics culture and
that are going to change the human
condition overall and business
specifically I write and I consult the
business audiences and what Minecrafters
mean is the way you treat customers
today is going to change when this
generation gets to college age which is
now four or five years old when we
started talking about the Minecrafters
was ten years away and the remedy for
this is to have an enlightened human
being the remedy for this there is no
place better than the science fiction
thinkers like Gene Roddenberry Isaac
Asimov prophecy Clarke I love these guys
Ernie Cline who did already play award
these my heroes these are the guys who
inspired me these are the guys who got
me into Silicon Valley but they're no
fiction they were fiction because they
were just making stuff up and I'm a
journalist and I'm not supposed to make
stuff up although a weapon tempted from
time to time just making them well a lot
of what a lot of what you've done is
you've helped people understand what
current technologies are doing and how
they're affecting culture how they're
affecting business and what is likely
going to be happening in the next couple
of years and that is a really important
position to to help people in so ok let
me I'll follow up on that's
wanna be my resume over the board but
that's what I'm trying to do good good I
think it's a really important position
to have there's not enough people like
that so I'm really happy that I'm you're
in that and I'm scold was in that and
there's a couple other people that were
II mean to have that are I'm excited too
I'm just wonderfully meet her and host
her I would really love that I'll set it
off set it up and her PR agents know
that's crazy at 12 percent she comes up
here regularly and the next time she
comes up I think she's she's in Los
Angeles
she's in LA okay great so it's that's a
crucial role and it's especially for
young people for kids to be well as they
progress into the world to be able to
hear about what all these technologies
are doing how they're affecting society
how the kids can become more actualized
by leveraging the technologies they're
kind of democratizing or even
decentralizing education in many ways
and then you have other countries like
Latin America and South America and
Africa and Asia and a lot of places in
the world that previously weren't able
to basically leapfrog technologies now
they can observe molecules in 3d in
front of their face thanks to this they
can they can observe a robot in action
in an augmented space or even in the
physical reality in front of them and
learn about that rather than needing it
again just leapfrogging all of this so
that is so profound and so important so
what do you think about how we have so
much wealth that's being concentrated in
just a couple people and so little
wealth with so many others even though
that the Pinker argument that overall
everyone's getting better over time is
very true cooker crunch
that's embarrassing hey there's no
embarrassment we're just chatting all
right so so overall everyone's going up
over time but what do we do about that
gap and as all these advancements in
technology kind of amplify wealth
inequality what do you think we should
do about that I don't think what I think
we should do about that will happen but
I'm a child of the 60s and I want us all
to join hands and sing Kumbaya and I
want us to tolerate all people I want us
to you and I probably know that we agree
on 92 we probably won't get to conflict
until I say the Giants suck my soul not
in conflict team is sports that's what
they are and if you say good or bad at
the end of that then they're already
being polarizing it's crazy how that
works but that polarization used to be
fun and now it gets serious
now at the end of the games fans get
killed Achille Jack we have entered a
time when the natural societal or
nursers have stopped happening history
is a case of going this way and that way
America's experiments have shown that we
will always go too far in one direction
than them back to the middle middle and
now we seem to be going too far in one
direction or direction I liked under
Obama didn't inflamed millions of people
that Obama supporters weren't noticing
so now we're going too far even further
in the other direction and these kind of
violence shifts from one side to the
other going on all over the world the
return of an empire mentality in in
Russia the installation of somebody who
can
willful life for the first time since
Mao in China the dangers North Korea
actually trying to prove that they
really really do have a button that they
can pop and the size doesn't matter that
much because they can sell that soul in
22 seconds or something like that we're
in a very dangerous time and during
dangerous times in history we end up
having citizen revolutions the French
Revolution the American Revolution the
colonies of Africa we are heading into a
time when so few have so much and so
many have so little and anger is
mounting and the channels of
communication are dwelling upon the
negative and and the dangers in things
like Fox have called real news that if
we do not find a way to head back toward
a common ground a place where we realize
that I and a Ku Klux Klan guy in
Mississippi do have things in common
ideas we can share ways we can deal with
each other a certain civility and you
both need to breathe air to surviving me
to eat food and drink water to survive
there's yes if commonalities there great
more than that though it's not that cut
and dry there are some people that lean
either way from whether it's right or
left it there are those have anything to
do with the climate and so then doesn't
breed the same here because they're
willing to let us breathe air that if
they rich they don't have to breathe
they'll be in climate-controlled
buildings does that some part let's get
away from like the word literally in
general like let us get that is for
polarizing in general versus saying us
we are polarized it just on a personal
level
most people assume I'm liberal I'm not I
I have for over thirty years and I've
been a member of either party except in
California
have to declare when I go vote in a
primary and then I have to read to clear
myself as an independent right
afterwards I voted for many Republicans
until about 15 years ago when the
Republican Party started to get it
headed by a bunch of nut cases and
that's not a political view because I
believe the Republican view the business
can usually solve problems that are
motivated by capital gain is wiser than
the very liberal view the government
regulation can fix massive human
problems yeah I believe in the middle of
these two wisdoms this should be a
friction that goes forward improves
education improves well-being
improves the state of old people
improves let's go on and on and on to
talk about these rules we can talk about
people that used to be safely taking
care of an institution's now sitting on
street corners of Market Street
injecting drugs into their bare feet
yeah and as a common sight in San
Francisco one among forward-thinking in
civil cities in the world it's not
you didn't say wow did you see that yes
I went this morning before 10:00 a.m.
when I arrived here the turn to me that
the surprise was I wasn't surprised yeah
we're in a very dangerous time we have
solved problems for 50 years the Texas
solved some of the smartest people in
the world believe there are dangers the
Technic was solving one of them left the
world recently Stephen Hawking Elon Musk
is another one that the things that I'm
a proponent of they're saying if you
take it far enough eliminate humanity
I'm hopeful that humanity exists long
enough to take it that far it's we are
in the most dangerous times I've seen in
my seven decades of life we are going in
a direction of more dangerous more
polarized times and you asked me what we
should do about it I don't
but we better figure it out fast I
thought my generation we were the
sixties kids we were going to give you
world peace and a clean planet and we
kind of watched those two but we did
give you the personal computer we did
give you the Internet we did give you
the smartphone you guys take it from
here will you but hurry up yeah yeah
because the health bar on the planet is
definitely having some issues bringing
it down I don't think there's a
political solution in the world to our
problems I think it's up to people but
for people to succeed they have to
change the political mixture of things I
don't see how to do that
I look to your generation to have better
ideas I look to a generation that
doesn't know or doesn't care what I've
seen in the course of my life so that
they can go in new directions the way my
generation didn't really appreciate what
her parents did when they went through
World War two and the Great Depression
before that and a lot of people in our
generation do care about what was passed
to them and a lot of people in our
generation do care about solving the
existential risks that we face I think
your generation is very attuned to that
and is very passionate about it and
there are other ones that are not and
that's also in it there are some people
that argue that that is totally fine for
people to give no [ __ ] about improving
the world and I think that that's now
that I don't think that's okay and I
strive to inspire people to care to
improve the world and this disease I see
it a little differently I think through
history there have been people who have
tried to improve the world and they've
done great things through history
some of them religious leaders of
earlier times perhaps one of those right
now is the Pope and I'm certainly not a
Catholic but we have a pope who is
showing that his church does have a
caring for the poor for ignorance
does have a passion for peace no matter
what religions are fighting the wars
there are people like that now the
problem is there were other people
throughout history who are most
interested in massing personal wealth
yeah correct and that's a with power
greed corruption ego you know we saw me
nan de kept saying it on our show but
it's all about inner management if you
can learn about your inner meditation
and spirituality it'll do things like
give you the wake-up call of like oh
that's actually not as important as
helping make the world a better place
then accumulating enough wealth to
purchase that third boat I had yeah I
had I had a I had a question about I
wanted to ask you
well I'll walk you down a couple more of
these simulation questions and then
we'll we'll call it a show what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world
can you put it in a box like made by
humans or oh anything then I'll get
poetic and say a baby's first smile I'll
ignore the fact that's probably caused
by gas but have you ever seen a newborn
baby smile yeah it always has to say
look of I'm here with away oh there yeah
I say baby smile okay good good okay
now deep she'll do you think we're alone
in the cosmos
we keep bouncing into sci-fi Arthur
Clarke it is very well known for the
2001 etc series - the is a menace Rama
he did a full book series on Rama were
and he also did childhoods end which had
the same concept of everything the
universe is created by a higher power
but that higher power may have been
accumulated and the wisdom of all living
things from blades of grass to humans to
other sentient creatures on other
planets in other galaxies and so the
only way I can get close to religion is
to take it out to the level of how did
the universe get here and where is here
if here is not the universe and what
happens to intelligence when we all die
and intelligence and soul or whatever
you want to call it is something that
may go somewhere when we cease to exist
so that probably moves me from being an
adamant atheist which I am when we talk
about organized Western religions that
I'm familiar with - a hopeful agnostic
at best but yes I believe there has to
be not only intelligent not only life
elsewhere but intelligent life elsewhere
what I think is what makes us unique
which is something else Arthur Clarke
dealt with we seem to be the only human
creature in the world that just likes to
kill things for reasons other than pure
survival yeah
then there are probably other
evolutionary examples of animals killing
other animals just for sport no sigh I
was raised there is problem I was told
the Wolverine was that but then I found
out that's not true that they have to
train a certain way but that's very
interesting it might not be true so
we'll have to investing in figure that
out sharks do it for food I cannot think
of any creature I know of routinely
kills for food maybe either other than
human being or routinely eliminates
races to own property you know stuff
like that is very messed up killing
people and killing people we could buy
based on religion and the stranger in a
strange land if we're gonna go down the
sci-fi Heinlein we had Martians who had
no concept of owning property it just
wasn't part of it they had no word for
war which is ironic because we humans
have named their planet for the God of
War but the you know a stranger in a
strange land he owned Mars the stranger
did you know what to do with it and our
government wanted to kill him because
they wanted to colonize Mars and I don't
know of any other human that is like
that and we have always been like that
so when we think of solving the problems
of the world and we we don't say that we
can reprogram humans or retrain humans
then we must accept that we are a race
that likes to kill we must really think
deeply about what we wish to do about
that if if the general principles of
humanity being that we are this only
species that likes to kill for fun what
are what do you who do you think is
going to be programming ethics and
humans own I should write narrow AI is
ours the theory is that we will be a
eyes at some point in the future I
personally have doubts but I'm not as
smart is Hawking you and musk or pretty
serious thinkers and I don't know
sorry about that right I don't know what
the resolution is I don't know if our
tendency will lead to the destruction of
this planet if there is a destruction to
this planet I don't know how that will
impact the rest of the universe
is there luke disturbance and the vortex
I don't know
you think artificial channel toast poses
a threat though right I think every step
of progress has always posed this worth
like nuclear war as well yes that
creates problems that tech fixes but
which where does it come
that's a continuum and always there is
no always it always has it's true but it
always will nothing had yeah we don't
ever know that the universe always has
been
or always will do yeah yeah okay if it
isn't what is there that that goes
beyond my IQs ability to calculate with
or without big data or assistants do you
think that we're in a computer
simulation
when I was in college and I took
creative writing I described us as being
on a mark in a molecule of water in a
glass of water being about to be
consumed by a much larger big and that's
the best thinking I ever did on the
subject and the question is yes I like
that and if we are a simulation or a
million molecule in another dimension or
something at the end of a wormhole were
the really good stuff is on the other
and I think it's irrelevant to me and
everything that I know of right now and
it gives me some comfort
to think that there is a higher
relevance but the side of a universe
that did not contain humans breaks my
heart yeah and like other humans are
kind of like us being a dominant species
I just wish we didn't have to kill so
much yep so that we could at least take
a firm benevolent control of this rock
and move forward to the next rocks and
help eradicate suffering do all the good
things on this planet so this has been a
pleasure this has been a huge pleasure I
can't wait for the next you know three
five years we're gonna be augmented
reality is going to be right here and
it's going to be impacting all of us a
lot of us are on the world and even just
three or five years hopefully there'll
be a billion people wearing a are by
then and and in past that we'll see
exactly how it ends up I have this I
have this video that I want to see if I
can if I can try and find drew ever sure
see that video of of the I think the guy
in South America that's wearing a are
that's walking through the streets yeah
I did do you saw that video yeah that's
a really good one I like that a lot
let's see augmented reality we had a guy
who used to walk around Silicon Valley
as good as new
with the camcorder in his head
live streaming he had a company for it
so he walked around and wherever he was
and one point again overall a million
viewers to follow that video - oh good
but just to finish the I tried most of
us eventually wandered away because it
got really really boring watching this
guy walk you know when she said go to
the bathroom once the interest of how he
was going to do that one away Ron do you
wanna play the video that I found Andy I
scan converter or no or otherwise I can
just go pull it up over there I play
okay great
hyper-reality so right now we're
watching this video okay
that's right look here oh yeah
[Music]
you know here this machine Facebook yeah
here's incoming call
oh it's getting your mic from on your
laptop I'm gonna figure that dystopian
crap
this is still cat truth it's just
because we can't you know we gonna get a
fake no it's it's just the way they're
taking up your your mic on your laptop
we get it up we get it looking so here
you can see there was an incoming call
there was a message you know here's your
google asking a question then there's
you know your friend group up there your
achievements your you know your level
and your points manager and so just like
it really quit going through this like
loyalty points will be erased okay here
you're walking you rate the bus driver
on the way out look at this they'll give
this a world right here your here's
clear the area because the light the
lights changing so you need to get out
of the street and then you know it's all
ads it's so crazy and you know you get
in the rest you get in the grocery store
yeah when there's your little pet thing
this is the old this is really
fascinating right here so there's some
like hiccups that go on right here
what's happening on my points safe right
and so that's the question because he's
getting like this you know this this
this issue with reality is being kind of
hacked by somebody and so and so look
this is what it looks like when it's off
and then here is the reset and then he
goes from level 99 you know it's look
going at level zero he's really worried
because you've accumulated all these
life points and so the hacker ends up
successfully you know right here this is
where he gets a blood sample look at
this watch and boom just like that
injury detected if your blood gets
stolen like that then they can you know
they're hacking in him reset your
identity erase your profile biometrics
accepted all that stuff sorry set and
just like that boom now you have to
start a new career a new life here it
found the religion but that's just in
essence you know we just went through
that succeed a video really quickly but
I wanted to at least you know end with
people understanding that that's kind of
the both in many cases a positive
example of how you can have all these
augmentations going on in the world in a
very negative example and so it's really
important that when we design the
technology that we bring into the world
that we do with an essence of some sort
of ethics with some sort of an
understanding that it could potentially
be harmful or an or and a given an
existential threat and to try and you
know democratize it to as many people as
possible get them educated get them
excited about it I'm really grateful
that you came on the show that your work
over the last twenty years has been
about trying to get people to get more
understanding of the technologies that
are up and coming in a plot apply those
to their lives so shell such a pleasure
thank you so much thank you
this was great let's get a Irene arena
arena on the show let's go you know on
the show and thank you everyone for
tuning in if you had a good time like
comment subscribe make sure to let us
know what you thought was interesting
what you thought we could improve on
what you think about augmented reality
and AI in the future of work also if you
think the contents useful share it with
other people we'd love for you to do
that big thank you to our partner
producer Ron Vargas for just crushing it
all the time thanks to our leading
patrons find us on patreon help us out
help us sustain the studio
space we greatly appreciate that thank
you everyone and we'll see you in a
little bit with david hua on the future
of cannabis later today thank you
touch of cannabis
[Music]
[Applause]